hey Doug Walker here I just got out of
an early screening of the movie heredity
this has been getting a lot of buzz it's
like you know the kind of scariest movie
of the year and it's super well-written
well directed well acted everything and
it's super disturbing uncomfortable and
yeah that's about it man this movie was
rough it's it's very well acted it's
super creepy it's I can't recall a movie
where like I kind of breathed heavily
during it like after a scene was over
like a scene or two I would just go the
guy to catch my breath but what's
interesting about it is that some people
and everyone I think will kind of get
what they're looking for
but there's a very distinct kind of
separation between the first half and
the second half I feel like people are
either gonna love the first half more
than the second half or love the second
half more than the first half I'll get
to that a bit but I
this is spoiler free the most I can say
about it cuz the least you know going in
the better is that it's about a death in
the family and the things that happen
after that that's really the most I
should say in terms of the film itself
in terms of like that the mood and the
tone I think one of the reasons it works
so well is that the first half of this
is really just creating this
unbelievably uncomfortable disturbing
feeling of dread I mean just this
absolute that's the only word I can use
it's just dread you're just watching it
and like I said after so many of these
scenes I just would take a breath
because it is just so uneasy and there's
so many scenes particularly in this
first half where I mean I'm just you
kind of don't want to watch it and it's
it's not yeah there is some gore but but
that's not particularly even the reason
why it's just these performances with
this family and what they talk about it
how they talk about it to me in many
respects is kind of a scariest part of
the movie and
it's not like a boo or anything like
that uh but it's just watching this
family interact off each other after
this death and it's just you feel it I
mean you just feel like you're in the
room listening to him say just these you
know awful but truthful things it's one
of the few times where you know you
always say that don't keep things
bottled up you know you communicate and
stuff like that but I mean later with
this I'm like no you guys probably
shouldn't be saying half what you're
saying but it's it doesn't feel quite
exploitive it just walks that tightrope
of not quite being like an exploitation
movie for the first half's that can have
a little bit of a different different
story but but again it still works the
best comparison I can draw to this is
that it's kind of like a mix between
Rosemary's Baby and The Exorcist
now that's high praise so clearly it's
not as good as either of those but it
has a very similar feel where the the
reason the scares in the second half
work as well as they do because the
movie doesn't really turn straight-up
horror until roughly the second half but
the reason it works so well is because
it creates this environment where you
are just so uneasy and it feels real and
because of that you feel like you're
with them more in these scenes when the
scary stuff starts happening because if
this movie source start off with the
stuff that happens in the second half
kind of in the first half like a lot of
horror films do it would have worked as
well it had to really create this really
just disturbing environment so with that
said the there is a very distinct
separation between the first half and
the second half like there are clues
being set up and everything but the
first half is very much a super
slow-moving uncomfortable family I don't
see drama because it because it there
are horror elements to it but it's
mostly watching this family interact off
each other and just this incredibly
uncomfortable unnerving way and then the
second half goes
more traditional horror and it's done
well it's done very very well uh but in
my opinion it kind of like I said people
are gonna love the first half more
they're gonna love the second half more
I like the first half more because
everything was a little bit more vague
you didn't quite know what was going on
but it was just enough that kept you
interested and it you questioned
constantly who's crazy here who isn't
crazy who has their head together and
who doesn't because just suddenly these
things are thrown at you they're so
strange and so odd and you're not sure
if it's legit or not but then when you
see certain things starting to move and
starting to happy you're like well wait
maybe it is uh but for some people they
might be going in saying well yeah I
know it's gonna be real or I know that
shit's gonna happen it's a horror film
so why don't we get to that faster but
for me I think because I've seen that so
many times in horror films
I feel like this starts off as a great
movie and then it becomes a good horror
film and the because for me when they
start getting explaining what's going on
I felt like I personally didn't need
that I just because there were little
clues in the opening serve indicating
what was going on and when you see it
all kind of come together at the end I
did realize I'm like man fer for the
family dynamic that was going on what it
amounts to really did not connect much
to what they were building up with the
family like why we were watching them go
through as much as they were going
through but it could very well be that
they're just setting up the second half
which you know again is sort of giving
you the answers and explaining what's
going on which is still good it's not by
no means bad and these performances just
sell it I mean these are just amazing
performances and it's so well directed
and I don't know maybe I need to see it
again maybe I need to I am gonna see it
again actually I'm getting my wife to it
and it's one of those films where it's
like I think I want to watch it and see
if there is more of a connection with
the second half to the first half
because I felt like
wasn't much particularly when it ended I
was saying well that was very disturbing
very creepy but I was like man that was
a house a different movie in the second
half like a good movie but that did not
feel like what the first half was
building up to which again you could say
well kind of a surprise and catches you
off-guard which it does but it's one of
those things where I feel like if they
kept it more vague I probably could have
drawn more connections to what the
family was going through with the horror
elements because what I loved about the
first half and kind of the middle is
that the horror imagery really reflects
what's going on with these characters
emotionally like one of the characters
sleepwalks and so half the time you
don't know if you're watching you know
this character really do something
terrible or if it's just in our mind or
she's sleepwalking and half the time the
air characters don't know to because
they start having bad dreams too and
then suddenly she'll just be in the room
you know with like the Sun or something
like that that sounds like what are you
doing here you were trying to do this
and she's like no no you're you're
dreaming it's not true now let me tell
you about this other crazy thing that's
going on your life and again that's
that's the brilliant part of this movie
is when you don't know who's in the
right mind or are they all out of their
minds and this is all from you know this
death that happens so that's the
absolute brilliant stuff I think that
the first half in the middle is just
like I mean like one of the great horror
films in my opinion and we get to the
end it becomes a really good horror film
but not one of the greats in my opinion
um but again I'm wondering if I need to
see it again I'm wondering if there is
more of a connection that maybe I didn't
see because there is stuff set up in the
first half to sort of to give you clue
as to what the third act is gonna be but
just emotionally I felt like this is not
where it should have gone like it should
have gone maybe in a different direction
like definitely a scary direction don't
get me wrong or messed up direction but
yeah I felt like when they start do it
doing the thing where it's like oh I I
looked through these books and I found
this and I found out that this character
is doing this thing and I found out that
like that's feeling like a movie and
this film was so good it was just
feeling like this
disturbing uncomfortable experience that
you were just witnessing you know it's
kind of like the closest I felt to being
in a you know watching a play or when
the play is really good you just feel
like you're just watching these people
unfold and their emotions unfold before
you and they're really right there I
mean this movie was getting so good it
just felt like these characters were
right there and you were in the room
with them so I think when you get to the
last third like I said people who are
either gonna love that because they're
gonna get answers or they're gonna sort
of be pushed away a little bit because
it it becomes them it just becomes a
horror movie a good one a really good
one but it goes from a great experience
to a good horror movie so I'm really
curious what people are gonna think
about that
my guess is everyone after seeing this
they're gonna like like you know how
people are saying I see people after six
sense I feel like everyone's gonna be
going after this it becomes less scary
as goddamn sound in this movie so even
like kind of the traditional you know
I'm sure people won aids it's like a
monster film where there's a lot of jump
scares and stuff like that there are a
lot of traditional elements and scary
music and stuff but there's not too much
of like the choten you know there's
definitely nothing where someone just
puts their hand on someone it's like
Sean it's just me there's none of that
bullshit none of the fake outs at least
not that I remember because I mean most
people hate them they grown by me for
the most part people watching this
whenever there's like just a scary scene
going out there's kind of that nervous
laughter like and whatever something
really uncomfortable or disturbing
happened in the first half people were
just I mean like it got the reaction it
was supposed to get so so like I said
going into this I think you have to know
this is while it is a scary movie and
there are sort of the traditional
paranormal scary movie elements to it it
does get rough particularly in the first
half and I think when it's really
fantastic well when it's really just
fine
is when the emotions the characters are
going through are being reflected in the
horror imagery I think that's when it's
just primo like well one of the best
horror films I've seen in years I mean
just it makes you so uncomfortable I do
not scare easy honestly I can pry count
on two hands how many like really great
scary horror films I've seen I mean I
just don't scare easy uh and this one
really was getting under my skin I mean
this was really creating an environment
that was just so uncomfortable and so
unnerving and just knew how to use the
music and knew one to go quiet and and
these performances were just so good too
I mean like I said they just totally
suck you in so I really like it if
you're looking for a traditional kind of
like just boo horror film I mean you do
get that eventually and it's done very
very well
but you gotta way through a lot of
emotion a lot of character which I love
I love that stuff even more and if
you're looking for that you know it a
more character in your horror film that
is definitely there to you might be
pushed back a little bit by the ending
because like I said it's by no means bad
but serve the brilliant steps that it
had in the first half and in the middle
go down a little bit to become a
traditional horror film in fact honestly
there's a few scenes in here when
they're explaining what's going on most
of the time you don't see the person
talking explaining it or like if they're
showing close-ups of books and stuff
like that so I'm kind of wondering if
that was put in later because it kind of
felt like it like I said it was becoming
that the last half particularly last
third becomes more of a movie instead
this very unique experience but it's
still a good movie so I I got nothing
but high praise for this movie that this
is just a really uncomfortable creepy
unsettling film and I think I don't know
I think a lot of people are going to see
if they're going to be talking about it
some are gonna be turned off by either
the first ever the second half but
there's there's at least one half
movie you're gonna love that's what
that's what I'm taking out of it
I like the whole thing but I think
everyone's gonna love one half of the
movie whether it's the first half of the
second half so I definitely really
really recommend go seeing it I think
it's a good creepy movie I don't know if
it's a good you know take your date
horror film because like I said I mean
it is really rough particularly the
first half but yeah I still highly
highly recommend it if you're a fan of
scary movies or any kind of just
uncomfortable movie going experience
which I know it's that's a weird thing
like why would you wanna go and see an
uncomfortable movie but I mean this
doesn't well and it's artistically well
done and visually it's wonderful and the
sort of some nice imagery and symbols
with like going into the doll house and
stuff like that like even the opening
shot it kind of gives you that feeling
of like there's manipulation going on
and stuff and they're all kind of
puppets and dolls it's just oh it's so
good it's really really good
so definitely go check it out I thought
was wonderful
get the shit scared out of you and
you